why are you broke have you ever asked
yourself that question our money is not
the important money doesn't buy
happiness oh my goodness let me think
then you think you're broke now you may
have heard of the saying people say well
I love this so much I will do it for
free I think it is a broke person's
mentality leave motivation watch a top
10 with belief nation
what's that belief nation it 7 I believe
in you and this channel is designed to
be a part of your daily success routine
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and join today's lessons from a
man who went from having his first job
working at a local grocery store when he
was 16 to failing multiple ventures as
an entrepreneur to eventually becoming a
self-made millionaire by the age of 27
he's Dan Locke and here's my take on his
top ten rules a success vol 5
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have an entrepreneurial mindset save
yourself before you try to save the
world the best way to help the poor is
not to become one of them it is your
duty it is your obligation it is your
responsibility to maximize your profits
as an entrepreneur think about it let me
give an analogy it's like if you want to
give blood how many bags of blood you
can give before you pass out and die
[Music]
that's that's linear thinking that's an
employee mentality you want to give
blood bill hospital that's
entrepreneurial mindset that's
entrepreneur mindset now some people may
say but then money is not that important
right oh man you know money doesn't buy
a happiness I'll talk to my wife
you don't think money
yeah if you talked to her she would say
you know you'll think money can buy
happiness you don't know where to shop
okay and money here's the thing money
it's not supposed to buy you happiness
money is supposed to give you two things
how many things two things first money
gives you comfort makes your life a
little bit easier and second thing is
money allows you to do to extend the
goods that you do beyond your physical
presence to only two things when people
want to hear oh yeah my name is not the
important money buy something buy
happiness very often oh it's a stupid
statement first of all but second thing
is usually it's a defensive statement
it's usually people would say that you
either don't you don't have any oh they
don't they don't know how to get some
guarantee so from now on you can be a
psychic you hear people our money is not
the important money doesn't buy
happiness oh my goodness let me think
let me think you're broke and it would
be like how do you know rule number two
love what you do what would you do
non-stop even you never got paid for it
no is not playing video games that's not
what I'm talking about
what are some the skills some value some
expertise you can offer to help people
even you never got paid for it you know
if you remember there was a scene in the
Dark Knight and the Joker said well if
you're good at something never do it for
free he was talking about the gang side
the Mafia trying to kill Batman
I believe that's true if you're good
with something you're good at something
never do it for free now you may have
heard of the saying people say well I
love this so much I would do it for free
I think it is a broke person's mentality
it's a very 97-percent mentality here's
my belief and you don't have to buy my
belief but he's my belief I believe in
life you should find something and you
would say to yourself you know what I
love this so much
it is the only thing I
- for money when you can find that when
then when you can identify your
brilliance when you can find something
that you truly enjoy doing then your
work and your life becomes one it's not
so much I go to work and I finish work
and I go home then don't talk to me
about work it's no it's working life
integration you love what you do life is
work and work it's life then guess what
you never have to work another day of
your life because work doesn't feel like
work anymore rule number three develop
high income skills you of Brooke why are
you Brooke have you ever asked yourself
that question
and how do you never be broke again I
was broke when I was a teenager when it
came to Canada with nothing no money and
was in debt a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in debt I was so frustrated I
try so many different things
I started and fail at thirteen
businesses thirteen not three not ten
thirteen businesses or disaster not only
did I make money from the businesses I
was in debt lost all my mom's money
borrow from friends and family and I
didn't know why I wanted to succeed so
bad but I just couldn't make it work
until one thing until I had an epiphany
what is that PIFAN II you don't have a
money problem you have a skill problem
if you try to solve your money problem
with just money your problem doesn't get
solved money problem is not solved by
money money problem is solved by your
intelligence and your skill set your
mindset and your skill set now what am I
talking about your skill set I want you
to think about some of the highest pay
people in the society they say doctor
they say attorney let's say lawyer let's
say accountant engineer who is making a
decent pie income
what do they have they have specialized
skill sets that me you may not have see
the people with low-income skills in
society in our society low-income jobs
chances are desk used now that doesn't
mean it'll work hard it doesn't mean
they don't hustle
it doesn't mean they'll work long hours
but the skills that they have that they
offer to the marketplace to society
people companies they are not willing to
pay big money for I call them low-income
skills that's the problem you try to
make big money with low-income skills
you need to develop your high income
skills in order to make more money so if
you're struggling in life you're
struggling in business I can guarantee
you the biggest issue how I've overcome
how I was struggling how overcome not
want to be broke again it's I learned to
close
I learned to communicate ideas thoughts
concepts when you learn to close you'll
never be broke again because in business
nothing happens until something is sold
in life nothing happens until something
is sold you're single you're not good
closer
you can't go you're not getting our
people to do what you want they're not
following your leadership you can't
close you're not getting sales because
you're lousy closer you can't close when
you can close you can move you can
influence you can persuade people
everything that you want in life guess
what other people already have them I
don't care what is it you want resources
money capital influence relationships
whatever it is that you want you got a
close someone else to give it to you so
if you're struggling financially it
means you're a lousy closer it is that
simple what that's the downside upside
is this once you know how to close you
will know how to create income on demand
you will know how to make money you have
the ability to make money anytime you
want
that's the power of closing that's how
you never go broke
again rule number four do whatever it
takes
business is tough I fail at 13
businesses before having my first
success so my question is how bad do you
want it see statistics 96 percent of
companies go out of business fail they
all fail within the first 10 years it
means that only 4 out of 100 companies
make it in 10 years so you look at an
audience of a thousand people in 10
years time only 40 of you would be still
here so business a game of business it's
not for the weak the game of business is
not for the wannabe the game of business
is for the ambitious the game of
business is for the committed the game
of business is for the people who do
whatever the it takes to succeed rule
number 5 don't be controlled by media
the mainstream media and advertisers
they want you to consume why do they
want you to consume is so that they
could better control you starting at a
young age you were taught to spend money
that you don't have to buy things you
don't need to impress people you don't
even like in your life you want to buy
that toys for your kids put down their
credit card you want take the vacation
put it on that credit card hey you want
to buy their Neil cotton you cannot
afford that's ok get a second credit
card borrow from your mortgage it's
perfectly normal to have some debt do
you have a lot of debt and that's the
problem that we have in the world
especially in North America
that's why families they are heavily in
debt and when you are in debt you are
controlled by the media and you're
controlled by the financial institutions
and your control by the banks remember
that rule number six have a strong why I
believe most entrepreneurs fail because
they start the business with the wrong
reason and intent every single time I
speak to a group of want to be
entrepreneurs or entrepreneurs and I ask
them the question how many of you want
to start your own business
and a majority of the hands we go
maybe 50 60 80 % then I would ask them
the next question why and usually I hear
one of these three things I want more
money I want to make more money or I
want more freedom or the most common one
it I one more one time now if you want
to start your own business or you have
the aspiration to start your own
business because you want more time
comment below
now the problem with this is M if
Michael Gerber talks about the book
email he said most entrepreneurs they're
actually not entrepreneurs they are what
we call employees suffering from an
entrepreneurial seizure and that's the
e-myth entrepreneur myth meaning that
one day they did something the boss yell
at them what they feel like they have a
good idea and they say you know what
this I'm gonna start my own thing they
are employee with employee mentality and
skill set but they're suffering from an
entrepreneurial seizure-like who know I
want to do this I'm gonna be my own
thing I'm gonna fire my boss and quit my
job and do my own thing right if you
want to start a business because you
want more time let me tell you this
starting a business because you're one
more time is as if you say I want to
have more time and have a baby I want
have a baby and I have more time it's
not gonna happen so you have to start
with the right intent start with the
right motivation and knowing that it's
going to take some time is you're not
gonna get more time in the first two
three five maybe even ten years and
you're okay with that can you endure
that frustration the pain that sacrifice
if not then don't be entrepreneur just
go get a job do something else this is
not your path there are other ways to
make money you don't have to be an
entrepreneur to make money
don't be sold on the idea that yes I
need to be entrepreneur in order to be
wealthy not necessary it's not necessary
there are the ways to make money rule
number seven serve a lot of people see
in my book a few money
I talk about freedom see freedom is not
the ability did not be ability whatever
you want it's not freedom is having the
luxury of not having to do something
when you don't want to so you don't need
to take crap from nobody that's freedom
because it makes no sense to me when you
work hard and you do your best and
students have to struggle to make ends
meet
I believe that entrepreneurs who do a
good job deliver value to the
marketplace deserve to be well paid let
me ask you a question how many believe
you deserve to be well paid hell yeah
you see money earned write this down
money earn it's a byproduct of value
creation money and it's a byproduct
value creation the more money you make
the more value you deliver the more
people it just simply means that the
more value deliver to more people more
impact the more money you gonna make I
make a lot of money because I serve a
lot of people is very very simple there
are some other people like you know of
Wall Street guys and this and that they
do it some other ways but most
successful people they're successful
because they serve a lot of people rule
number eight get clarity but when it
comes to reading I read a book sometimes
if I'm looking for any book that I read
I have a simple question I want to get
through what are the three ideas that I
can get from the book that can implement
right now just a suite not 10 not 20 not
100 three ideas if I could get those
three ideas from the first three
chapters I'll highlight those I will
take those and I'll put the book away
one of the most powerful tool when the
boat most powerful mindset you need to
have in life on business is clarity and
clarity is power clarity is power and
what is power the power is the ability
to take action
so if the more you read the more
confused that you get it gives you less
clarity it means it takes away from your
power if more reading gives you more
clarity and gives you more ability to
act that's good
that's powerful right that's that's on
the right track so there's a big
difference between information and
knowledge and knowledge to wisdom let me
explain this would gives you a lot of
clarity information is just facts data
numbers figures theories principles
that's just information there's a lot of
information on the Internet there's a
lot of information on YouTube there's a
lot of information on Google there's a
lot of information but information
itself does not help you it does not
make you richer it doesn't not does not
make you happier it does not make you
healthier it does not make you smarter
information is just information it's
like you need go to school right you're
reading you're going to class you you're
your textbook there's a lot of
information in the textbook right that's
the first stage once you gather enough
information now you're accumulating what
I call knowledge so you get a lot
information and you now learn about the
distinctions now you take that
information you apply or may take that
information and you you take a test
that's knowledge after the test you know
after the exam in school oh that works
so oh no that's what's the wrong answer
or I didn't pass the the the exam or
here they're the mistakes that I got
wrong well you're learning from it right
that's accumulating your knowledge so a
lot of people they read books to acquire
information you want to be there quite
information and you wonder how come I'm
watching a lot of videos I'm learning
but my life is do the same because you
haven't convert information to knowledge
and from knowledge into experience now
how to convert knowledge into experience
so now you get you acquire some
knowledge you
to implement and the only way you get
experience and you up a lot right
you make the mistakes you see this stuff
works right now you're getting
experience you're seeing a pattern of
things go goes back to the the school
example now you take enough exams
remember the class you take from like
grade 9 10 11 12 right now you're taking
of exams studying the same subject for
many years in a row now you see a
pattern okay
I'm accumulating more things I'm getting
more experience of what works and what
doesn't
now experience that's much more valuable
it's more valuable in knowledge and
knowledge is more available information
so books itself is just information
information does not change your life
information doesn't change your life you
got to convert it by gathering a filter
into knowledge from knowledge now you
implement now you get to the next step
which is experience then from experience
from now you you have done it long
enough a long period of time now is
evolved into your wisdom a lot of people
are smart but they're not wise wisdom is
something completely different
okay wisdom
[Music]
is knowing what not to do
wisdom is knowing when you don't have to
do something so let's say enough
experience you know what this is how I'm
going to make this work these are 20
things that I could do my experience
tells me these are the 20 things I could
do to make me successful wisdom is
knowing okay 19 these is [ __ ] just
do this one that is the difference rule
number nine understand the marketplace
so I always say the amount of money that
you make is in direct proportion to how
how deep you understand your marketplace
is pain the amount of money you make is
in direct proportion of how well how
deep you go how much you understand your
marketplace is pain so you have to
understand what it is one or the other
or what are the things that you will
have and how can you help them relieve
some of that pain and rule number ten
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is invest in good relationships
with mentors so when looking for a
mentor
yes let's say we take you out of the
picture yeah right
how do you know if they are in in this
just to to be a guru in so you should or
if they're actually are able to help you
you don't you don't it's like how do you
know is you just say any single people
in the room okay couple of people how do
you know when go on a date that that's
gonna be the one you just don't know but
you will find out pretty quickly you
will find out pretty quickly you look at
this stuff you connect with them are
they being helpful are they actually
helping you right and you can see well
you know yeah it is helpful then you
know you keep you continued relationship
the good thing about this simulation
ship versus like a marriage it doesn't
work you can you can stop anytime you
can stop calling them you can stop
asking them questions so I think it's
not being afraid just to ask and say
like just today is interesting today I
just finished an interview with a
gentleman called Cordell for my podcast
just before I came here
and
he is very successful zero entrepreneur
company doing about 50 60 million
dollars a year raised about hundred
million dollars and at the end of the
interview I said hey no Dell can I can I
can I ask you some stuff can I hire you
can I can you be my mentor they said
well you know Dan and I'm quite busy but
if you need help yes you'll be a mentor
I just asked I said I'm more than happy
to pay you
I pay my mentors don't feel like it's
not so much that your mentor doesn't
need your money
you understand that but paying them it's
it's some skin in the game and they know
you're serious it's just like I have
probably now a 12 a dozen entrepreneurs
they pay me a thousand bucks a month one
hour of my time every month thousand
bucks an hour you know it's not only the
money but if they pay that 1,000 bucks I
know that they're serious and they
they're gonna implement what I teach
them that's that's fine that's totally
fine so I do that little bit you know in
my spare time but that's what I mean
don't be afraid it you know invest in
your mentor you know I find my mentor
gifts I just like my mentor my Dan Pena
seventh birthday SMI nice gift
how can you expect your mentor to invest
in your relationship when you don't even
spend the time and effort in the
relationship it makes no sense you want
them to help you you want them to help
you grow you want em to help you succeed
but what have you done for them what
have you shown nothing they don't need
anything from you and I'm always very
humble very grateful all my mentors I
always thank them I appreciate what
they've done because it is it is because
of what they have helped me to do so
that's what I would say don't be afraid
you don't you will know but all you can
do is ask and then do it
now I've got two really special bonus
clips I'm dating on how to read books
and be willing to do the things that you
don't want to do that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to actually taking action in your
life or your business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below
here we go question number one who could
three potential mentors be in your life
number two how will you reach out to
them and bring value and number three
what one question do you want an answer
to from them
number one poor people watch TV and rich
people read books how many hours you
spend in front of the TV and when was
the last time you read a book how many
books do you week per year how many have
you heard of the saying that you know do
what you love and the money will follow
how many Ricardo did that before okay
it's a load of crap okay let me ask you
this let me ask you this how many of you
are doing what you love and you are
following your passion and you're
wondering what the hell is the money so
that dog doesn't hurt it does not work
you see it's the other day I was having
a conversation with a friend of mine
he's an international sales trainer and
he travels around the world and goes
into companies and and trains different
companies and we were having this
discussion about you know do what you
love and the money will follow and then
he said to me we know Dan you know what
I would love to do I would love to just
stay home spend time with my kids
holding my wife one hand you know
holding a beer and watching a hockey
game but the problem is you know what
then I can figure out to get people to
watch me do that and pay me so until
then I had to get on the road and travel
and train it's a lot of people yes you
want to follow your passion but you
better make sure your passion makes you
money you better make sure can you build
a Bible business from it can you get
rich at it yes follow your passion I
love what I do I love what I do I'm a
very passionate guy but there are
certain things in my business that that
I didn't like to do while I was building
a company nowadays yes I spend 90% of my
time doing what I love
let me give an example I love speaking I
love speaking teaching business I could
be here all day no scrip don't need a
script
problem is I hate traveling
hey and I got here last night it's like
it was horrible but it's because it's
because I am willing to do what I don't
like to do that's what allows me to do
what I do like to do does that make
sense so lesson number two write this
down it's not to you what you love and
money we follow is love what you do and
you'd be damn good at what you do and
you'd be exceptional at what you do hi
this is Dan Locke if you're a fan of
Evans work if you want to know exactly
how the model my success I want to
invite you to join me for a special
online training all you have to do is
click on a link below you can join me
for absolutely no charge so click on
link below and I will see you in class
if you want to learn the five powerful
habits that will change your life check
out the video next to me I think you'll
enjoy continue to believe and I'll see
you there the one habit that you must
develop that would change your life will
change your world is this one thing